the dodgers are going with the bullpen
and for nelson his first major league
start since the 20th of june 2019
while he was a member of the milwaukee
brewers
two and two from nelson is grounded past
the dive of justin turner into the left
field corner coop rounding first and
he'll get to second
well he had gone a couple of weeks
without an extra base hit got one friday
and gets one in his first day beat today
cooper at third two gone and a 3-2 pitch
a high strike three call letter high but
nelson doesn't care
[Applause]
pablo looking to bounce back a rough one
his last timeout perfect spot get him up
there behind bets get him more played
appearances
get him up there sooner and then
get him up there last
in the air left center field dickerson
is there to make the catch and pablo
works out of the first inning jam still
scoreless
[Music]
five six and seven for the marlins here
in the second isan diaz leads it off
jimmy nelson comes home and a fly ball
in the first pitch down the line
noisy race is over soda's really
look at the range that he can have with
those strides and as he gets closer he
does not go into the chop steps at all
he stays moving
those stride lengths stays the same and
that low fence is not big enough for the
big fella
oh so good that he is okay
swing and a miss two out
there they go here it comes he struck
him out
silvacia comes on he gets the job done
left in the first and third last inning
see if the bottom of the order can come
through here in the second with austin
barnes up there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and diaz came together and then neither
guy wanted to go too hard and run the
other one over
[Applause]
pitch number 60 for pablo lopez coming
up two balls two strikes two outs runner
does not go that's a swing and a miss
that is out number three here
in the third will roll to break two
nothing
[Music]
the 1-1 pitch to anderson is hit in the
air right center field racing back raley
not going to get there it's going to
bounce up against the wall going to the
opposite field brian anderson's got a
double to
put the man at second base here with one
out in the fourth inning
there aren't too many times it works the
other way around
oh pablo gets the strikeout we are
through four
two nothing dodging
like in his house or no
[Applause]
nice job by pablo putting the ball in
play
jazz oh for two grounds one up the
middle that's a base hit
[Music]
not trying to do too much but the
marlins get a little something going
here in the fifth that's what you love
to see
with the one two
he struck him out devilish changing
pablo to third jazz to second but now
two outs in the inning he'll need a two
out hit from
adam duvall
adam duvall with a drive out to left is
it gonna stay fair
yes sir three run home run adam duvall
and the marlins jump on top in the fifth
now the big guy's biggest swing of the
series
comes here in the fifth
marlins take the lead right now
adam duvall continues his hot streak i
mean again
he's uh made the dodgers pay the series
the second home run of the series a
fastball right down the middle
yanks one left center towards the gap
it'll split it and hit
there's two guys right there that could
easily be the faces of baseball
so it'll be up to matt beatty to try to
get bets around
pablo gears up for another 1-2 pitch
and beatty into right field to base hit
bets is around third here comes the
throw it's in time and wallach got him
on the leg
betts tried to jump over chad wallach
who just stuck the glove up and somehow
caught a piece of mookie betts in the
leg
applied the tag and they cut down the
run
marlins were wanting to get him
out to l.a
talk about that
on friday so second hit i'm going to
assume
wow
it's not easy
oh
he's trying oh i still
look he knows the camera's on him now
i'm not going to be embarrassed on tv
and bass gets him to chase a one two
three ending with a couple of strikeouts
for anthony bass marlins have a one run
lead going to the eighth
[Applause]
they've got him
[Applause]
go ahead run lux and none of it matters
fluoro against his former club
gets the strikeout we'll head to the
ninth
that's off his glove ricochets left side
bare hand
oh what a play
gavin lux off the deflection
bare hands and throws in one motion to
get the speedster chism is close but wow
what an effort by gavin lux the bare
hand play and barely [ __ ] his arm to
get it over there
bouncing ball towards the middle
chisholm with a diving stop throws right
and the tight one reaches
and will smith will come up representing
the winning run
that is out number two a big strikeout
for garcia sets smith down and the
marlins are in out away
nothing in two on bets ground ball to
third anderson up with it across the
diamond gets the out it's a marlins win